Sakana Lenin A's attempts to scare off
this swarm of locusts are almost
completely futile he's the chief of a
community of herders here in eastern
Kenya the eating this roughs until it is
finished we are very worried because
once there is no these small shrubs
animals can connect under the swarms
crossed from neighboring Somalia and
Ethiopia in recent weeks it's the worst
plague of locusts to affect the region
in 70 years
one locust by itself looks harmless but
it can eat its body mass in plant matter
every day and so a swarm of tens or even
hundreds of millions can eat tons of
food each day and that's devastating for
the farmers and herders who live here
it's dry for most of the year the people
depend on their animals to survive the
animals depend on the plant and the
plant are being devoured the government
started spraying insecticides which is
says a harmless to people and livestock
it's released two million dollars to
fund the fight against the locusts the
UN's
also contributed there are many farms in
the neighboring province there the
locusts could devastate food supplies
and the economy the response is meant to
stop that but it hasn't been working
well we found this swarm the day after
it had been sprayed this village
administrator told us the actions taken
so far haven't been effective and more
must be done we've seen that the number
they have come to kill me
very low number so I don't think that
it is working and so the locusts keep
eating and their population keeps
growing
but the agriculture minister told us the
insecticide is now working and the
swarms will soon be stopped the
chemicals to do are not really wrong one
I think is the mixing the intensity of
the ingredients that kill them that that
was a problem that has been corrected
government is taking total change of the
situation scientists say it was on
seasonal rains across the region last
month that caused the locust population
to boom it watered the plants they eat
and they'll soon start to threaten
people's food security if they're
feasting isn't stopped
Malcolm Webb al-jazeera Samburu County
Kenya